[Music]
this podcast has bad words
so i am i've recovered from like um an
eating disorder and gone through like
body image struggles and i've become a
food and body image coach over the last
couple of years to help other people as
well
and i know you guys grew up with you
know like
similar experiences and especially
growing up together i was just wondering
if any part of your minimalist journey
whether it was getting rid of clothes or
again like the self-relationship like
has any part of your journey whether
together or separate have been helpful
in like your body image and your health
and things like that yeah i used to
weigh 80 pounds more than i weigh now
and um
i remember
that i lost a bunch of weight but i was
holding on to i wasn't a minimalist yet
but i i
was holding on to all these like
shirts that were three or four sizes too
big for me and it was like
the ultimate just-in-case item i guess
just in case i plan on
gaining a bunch of weight but then also
being out of style three years from now
then i guess i'll hold on to these you
know and we
um we sort of buy these uh we were just
talking to karen from napo uh the
national so is she back oh yeah hey napo
uh the national association of
professional organizers they're here
tonight uh we gave a talk at one of
their conferences a few years ago and um
they get it like most of us don't
understand like you don't want to
organize your stuff we we go to the
container store we buy all these clutter
coffins and then we just hide a bunch of
our things and we turn our houses into
mausoleums of dead stuff
and and that's kind of what i did with
the but it also meant i was in a way
clinging to that version of myself and
when i let go of the the oversized
clothes those remnants of my past
similar to what matt was saying i was
like taking the things out of my
metaphorical backpack i no longer
identified with that person anymore
i was a heavyset kid my whole life and
so i'm still a heavyset adult you know
in my mind that's how it works and uh as
in
and uh i've struggled every day of my
life with my body every day and uh
and i find that letting go to quote
that the most important thing to let go
of now at this point
for me is the idea right the idea of
like
and i probably say to myself i'm fat or
to say it out loud
you know 10 times a day like truly just
like oh i'm fat i'm fat [ __ ] i'm fat i
got to lose some weight i'm fat i'm also
a compulsive person so it adds to the
fun but
but i find like that particular rock
that i carry in my backpack is like
way down at the bottom do you know what
i mean and it's like you no matter what
you kind of peel out that that image and
that idea
shows up i mean in everything i think
it's like princess and the pee it like
lives under the mattresses and you don't
even know it and then there are moments
where you lose weight if you're you know
i got shingles um a couple years ago
really bad and i got it around my
midsection and i'm convinced that like i
[ __ ] willed it to happen in the place
that i hate the most
and that it was like from neglect of
like you know what i mean and and uh and
so loving you know your body and that's
such an important part of the minimalist
idea is like what ideas aren't working
for me anymore and how do i carry them
and how do they just sort of decimate me
slowly over
the day the years all that stuff so
that's my i don't even know if i
answered your question but i i
commiserate with you in that way yeah
thank you oh man you know i was thinking
about um
when i did that packing party like
afterwards i was going through all my
stuff
and i had made the mistake of buying
clothes
that were too small
like
because they would be on sale
and i'd try it on and i'm like oh it's
like it almost fits but i'm gonna go
ahead and get it just for you know when
i lose that however many pounds
and uh yeah like had a ton of clothes
with tags still on them trying them on
and i'm just like what the hell was i
thinking
um yeah i had to let those go but i i'll
tell you the beautiful thing about
this whole journey that we've been on
is i really have learned how to
uh
just like love who i am like look in the
mirror and be like yes like i and it's
not like in this cocky
you know egotistical way it's like it's
a truly like connection with myself
where i'm like dude like i
[ __ ] love you man
and it took me a long time to get there
yeah yeah we only got one meat suit we
gotta love it for the rest of our lives
absolutely right yeah amen one meat suit
that's the name of the next book meat
suit yeah only one meets it
but you know to get to that to get to
that love for for for who i am it really
started with well it started with that
packing party like that's where the
minimalists.com started it was with that
whole story and what i realized was like
oh wow
uh
if you were to ask me hey ryan what are
your priorities i would have told you
like well good health and you know
relationships cultivating passion
growing contributing but when i looked
at all those piles of stuff that i had
still sitting in those boxes i'm like
that i was just giving all that stuff
lip service and now i really go out of
my way you know for my actions to align
with those values and like that is it's
a very simple recipe but we all know
like simple is not easy
um but but those actions aligning with
my values that's what has led me to this
um yeah to like really level myself and
it's taken me a long time to just accept
that like i have a very big chest i'm
very broad shoulder there's nothing i
can do about it so um yeah i've learned
to embrace that
oh i have big broad shoulders i can't
help i got these biceps
oh my jaw is so masculine it's a burden
[Music]
thanks for your question thank you
thanks so much
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free